Emilia is going to explain now using
member committee clustering our lives do
it determination of patina structures
please give her welcome applause well
good afternoon everyone and thanks first
of all to the organizers for giving me
the opportunity of talking to you about
some of the work I do and also to you
for attending to this talk so first of
all let me introduce myself I'm a PhD
student at the structural biology unit
in the action Boulder team in the
crystallographic method group and before
I ended up there doing my PhD I studied
a five-year deal in biotechnology and
the Masters in crystallography in this
idea I have learned all I know about
programming which is a little bit funny
with the Musgrave help of my colleague
mathematical form of economic computer
science so in this sense this synergy
that has been mentioned in other cells
has been really good and well I have
some knowledge of other languages
because of work duty in my degree or
some small project but basically all the
software we developed is in Python and
Python the tool we use for for all the
work so just a brief outline of what I'm
going to speak about the first we'll
talk about clothings and their structure
then about how do we get these protein
structures which is the actual
experimental method because we still
need experimental methods to get them
and how they - is helping us in this in
disgust so this is the third talk today
about protein so maybe I don't have to
go so much into the details but proteins
in a nutshell right so proteins are
relevant I think they have already
convinced you because they are basically
that the work is in the factory that our
cells are so they perform most of the
functions that are required based on
both molecules they respond to stimuli
they they are the workers in a factory
right and what they are composed of they
are proteins for the bigger chains of
amino acids good analogy that
commonly uses that they are like a
necklace with different shape this and
this they have this different shape
translated to amino acid means that they
have different size different chemical
properties and that will interact
differently with each other the actual
sequence that the of amino acids that
you have in a sign comes from the gene
that qualify for that protein so there
is a relation by the genetic code that
relates our genes with our protein but
the protein will not stay in this like
linear unfolded shape but rather the
amino acids will start interacting with
each other and will form this kind of
structure so the first level will be
what we call secondary structure and
this is also I want to make a phone we
we structural biologists I are very
visual and we'll also see pretty
pictures of the thing so you will
usually see alpha Ellis's in this
cartoon representation and beta stands
like this but the actual atomic view of
this is more like this and here you have
the interactions that are forming also I
think it's important to point out that
the beta strands are not usually found
well they are not found alone but they
are always a solution this type of
interaction with another one is in a
parallel or antiparallel fashion but it
is not the only level of structure a
structure gets more complicated and more
implicit and we have what we call
tertiary structure and this is for a
single chain but if more than one
protein chain is needed to perform the
function we have what we call a
quaternary structure so why do we care
about the 3d structure of reading as
massimo has mentioned before actually
the the 3d structure of the proteins is
basically what allows the protein to
perform its fashion and I think it's
good that we go to a specific example
because it's easier to understand it so
this is the structure of a protein we
saw a couple of years ago so this is
from another group in our department
that does the biological part and this
is from a pathogenic bacteria that
causes sting divide is another
inflammatory diseases and because our
collaborators determine with our health
this structure and also the structure of
related protein they did understand how
the actual mechanisms reaction work and
now they know how to tackle this
pathogenic bacteria so this it has
really a real-life application so I said
that we have already a mess information
that we have already information on
protein structures you know us today so
we have a database which is called the
protein that having and there is where
we sort this maximum alert structure
that we have already determined by
different methods and we will see one of
them from this table and so now we are
changing out to another format that
suppose you will be the standard and you
know the common way in which we have
said this information is this plain text
files that contain information about the
3d coordinates in the space all these
databases can be accessed in a
programmatic way which is really simple
and and you can receive not only
information about the coordinates but
more information that allows you to do
data mining like about the experiment
and so on so all these of this is really
easily accessible and one of the tools
in Python that you can use to process
PDB files is this library via Python
which is a general bioinformatics
library so it has it can do much more
than reading a PDF file but one of its
possibilities is dealing with this kind
of fight and I'll show you a small
example this protein if you bring in the
producer you already know it's a more
glowing the protein that carries oxygen
in ourselves and it's extracted from
both like four copies of the same
protein so what we are doing here in the
core part we are just opening normally
as a silo case in Python this PDB and
then we are instantiating the parser
class from this V of P DV module we are
obtaining the structure with this
structure method and say with these into
this kind of structured object and here
I wrote you two ways of accessing the
information then it says in a heretical
way so as we here we can we have here
the whole model with the for change then
we have one change then we have one
amino acid and for example in this case
we are interested in getting the carbon
alphas which are one of these atoms that
all the amino acids have has at for part
of the chain so I can iterate over each
of the levels of the structure or the
model some experimental methods produce
more than one more and that's why you
have this level here then on the chain
and then checking in each of the amino
acids if this happens there and saving
it to this list there is an easier way
with two lines to solve this
remembering this other way you could see
the death structure so I mentioned that
we need experimental methods to obtain
spectra so there is a relation between
the sequence of amino acids and the
final structure but we still didn't
figure out how to solve it and we need
experiments to determine and there are a
few approaches to do this but the one
which we work with with each great
diffraction so the issue with the
problem is that they are quite smooth
and in order to to be able to see them
we need to use we cannot use just
visible light and look them through a
microscope but what we need is a
wavelength that is small or very short
wavelength light x-rays however there's
a program it's rays are interacting
basically they are being observed it you
can image with x-rays so we need to
exploit another phenomena which is x-ray
diffraction and I wrote you here this
small deformation which is the the young
experiment which proved that the light
was having lots of this wave behavior
and not only particle so what you see
here is that we have this this asleep
here this is mostly and that life is
passing through here if it if it will be
this part because it will be hitting
here and
you will see just a single point in this
pattern but you see like some diffuse
scattering here when we have here
another two slits which are separated by
a certain distance what we get is like a
discrete pattern and there is a relation
between these and this so this
interferences between waves are
producing something here that we can
interpret and go also to this point
and we can use this with proteins but
the set up the experimental setup looks
a little bit different so first of all
we need super bright x-ray so they have
to be really strong and focused and in
order to that we need to go to particle
accelerator so here we have the Alvis
encoder which is the main source from
which we get the six rate and we then
just heat our protein with its raised
bit ugly but rather we use a protein
crystal and a protein crystal is not
very different from a mineral crystal so
it's some super well ordered arrangement
of proteins that you get and we do this
because we need like the amplification
effect of this instead of having one
protein and get some diffusive
scattering by having a lot of them we
get this constructive interference that
will be useful for us right something we
heat our protein with x-rays and we
detect be diffracted x-rays here right
but it's raised in the same way that
light has this wave behavior so they all
not only have an intensity but they have
a phase associated this is another like
the angle in which this radiation is
coming and we lose these phases we kind
of measure them experimentally we only
have the amplitude and in order to go
and get our electron density map and our
protein structure we do need the phases
we need to retrieve them somehow in
order to be able to compute our electron
density map so how do we do it they are
again different ways to solve this phase
problem which is the bottom leg into the
photography and one of them is what is
called molecular displacement so all
right we have already a database with
quite a huge number of structures that
have been sold and we have the
amplitudes from our data we have the
intensities that we have lost a face
maybe we can use the sizes from a
structure that is similar 12 and
computer electronics team up because
when we have coordinates we can compute
originally this is a relational
mathematical relation that we can use
however we need to solve to solve two
obstacles before first of all we need to
find a similar structure and in order to
do this we can use the sequence but
normally you know the sequence of the
protein that you have crystallized and
searching the database if there is
something similar in terms of the amino
acid but then we also need to find how
this model is oriented on crystal
because these are structure that you are
using as a model was obtained in a
different way and you need to put it in
your setup so how do we find your
invention of our model well most of the
modern molecular replacement programs
are based on something that some of you
might know in another context which is
the principle of maximum likelihood
within a sentence basically say that the
best model is the one that is most
consistent with your data but how this
translates to our case I'm going to show
you here with this simplified version of
the base theorem of the posterior
probabilities okay we are interested in
getting our posterior problem diesel
which is a probability the off of our
model of our structure given our day
that it is what we get in the
synchrotron this diffraction pattern
right so this will be equal to the
levels of the probability of that the
our day has reproduced by this model and
we need to take into account the
probability the prior probability of the
model itself is just like the distances
between the atoms as it should have but
this is similar this is equal for all
the the model so you don't need to use a
little worried about these no need to
take into account also the probability
of the data in order in the case of an
experiment is also always constant that
means that the procedure probability is
proportional to the likelihood so we can
use this likelihood as the charges for
doing our molecular abatement so at the
end what is molecular placement
is just trying in a set of possible
orientations and different rotations and
translations to place our similar
structure in our day than the one that
gives maximum likelihood is the one that
we take as a solution this is more or
less how how it was if it works one of
the the issues is that in molecular
replace and one of the more important
most important parameters that you need
to take into account is the similarity
between your protein and well your
unknown protein and the model that you
are using and the way in which we
measure this is with the
root-mean-square David can I get some
so I mentioned so the root-mean-square
deviation again is a concept that you
might have heard before but apply to
protein structure is just an average
will be of this sensor so in this case
here I have two all viruses and I have
got the distance between the CL c alpha
carbon and then I use these distances
here for this averaging and it is how
you complete the adamancy so here I
brought you a picture in which you have
on the x-axis the sequence identity
between two protein and in the y-axis
Vieira may see that they they have
between them so what you can see is that
like from 30 40 up to 100 the
correlation is good and also the
distribution is like very tight but when
you go 30 or below you have water lemon
seed but also your distribution doesn't
look it's much wider this is what they
is called usually the twilight zone
because it's this part in which the
correlation between sequence identity
adamancy is not so good and and because
you need to set the element C when you
have modes that are in this twilight
zone you need to take this into account
so how does this look like in structures
not so I mentioned the element see how
that is the looking reality so I have
here in purple if the structure that we
solve on some of the relate of the
structure of the envelope that were
available to use so in this first one
you have 40 pairs 46 percent sequence
identity and you see that theorem and
see these values 0.7 it is quite low and
why would this would possibly work with
molecular replacement and you see that
the the superimposition between them is
quite good if you go to these other
three structures that are on this
Twilight Zone threshold you see more bad
lady so you have for example this one
that is 26% and the elements increases a
little bit but you go down to 15%
sequence energy which is quite low
sequence near to the NFC the structure
is quite conserved or sometimes you have
things like this so you have 20%
sequence
she's low but the enmity is quite
terrible so if you will be to use this
model it will not be easy to to use it
for molecular basis especially not only
because there are some parts that are
different ways but because even if the
overall fault is similar there might be
like a slight adjustment that you will
need to do for example between the beta
strand in the middle and the LEDs on the
side so this will be as challenging kind
of model to use and sometimes your model
is working from a little hair
replacement actually and in what we do
in the group is to develop by some
planners at the front kind of with all
its knowledge standard molecular
greatness so we don't use this kind of
fool models but other types of things we
use what we call generally a small
fragment so we use this secondary
structures like alpha Alice's or a few
beta strands and we try in the same way
that our symbol the Italian painter with
the portraits like by using common
objects and the part we do like the same
back with the proteins in a way so we
have a number of programs we have
actionable the light that is the one
that use alpha is a dll file Isis we
have our simple Deportes which use like
libraries of poles that are obtained by
looking at this characteristic because
of maximum as mentioned in the previous
talk and one of the ocean is okay if I
don't have an animal and that is very
good but still I have a distant amount
of something that has not a very good
sequence identity but the fall bath
reader we can use it as a starting point
to to derive fragments and one of the
things we can do is to use our program a
symbol the further and what we can do is
instead of using the whole model cut it
like into compact pieces so we do like
special partitioning of the initial
model and then identifying groups that
we can like to refine against each other
like do like rigidbody refinement
between them in our molecular
replacement so how we can do this
partitioning or why do we want to do
this partitioning so here is an example
with a in place so this has been three
muscles
whatever is secondary structure so I'll
solicit some data sense and if I don't
define any group I have here the analogy
with the square will be like a final
structure we want to get and the
triangles are our models well if I don't
define any group I cannot fit this
anything better than this I have to
worry about the rotational relation
justice parameters but I cannot do
anything more if I then split it into
three groups for example the aliases in
one side the other releases in the other
side and a better sense I have more
parameters now to worry about but I can
adjust a little bit better if I then
leave each of the Alice's separated now
I went up to 21 parameters for each of
the rotation translation and observation
but even fits to a part of the structure
I can adjust my better so in a way I
need to find an agreement of not going
really to individual atoms or residues
but making groups that I can use for
giving the degrees of freedom to the
model so more or less the process of
this program does these are single
deliveries just taking this not so good
model trim it to secondary structure
annotate groups and this is what
community clustering will make its
appearance and then generate these like
compact models that we will use for
molecular placing right so again if you
think in the previous talk we have a way
to represent certain structures as a
graph or network and in our case the
graph that we used to represent it is a
complete undirected graph and what we
have in the birth distance is just a
secondary structure elements for each of
these beta strands or alpha Alicia and
then the agents have a way that is
proportional to the to the recent and it
can have more things into account that
the basic feature is taking total via
distance and there's like two different
questions that we want to ask to to
answer so what Maxima has in the cloud
which is more like the prediction or the
understanding of the structure through
through the
through through this small blocks to to
local in the PTV database but in my case
what I'm interested is to see which is
the best automatic way in which we can
select breakdown these models and help
in solving the structures that we still
don't know and for which we don't have
good models to start with so that's all
that I'm using to do the community
gathering and signing this group is
Python Agra and Python I graph in order
to perform community classes in which in
a sentence is basically searching for
these groups of nodes that are more
connected between them than with the
rest of the network it has a set of
different algorithms some of them based
on on different strategies there are
these face radiating vectors and
community multilevel that are based on
this model item which is this property
of being more connected there are some
of them that support directed graph so
this is not our case but for some of you
if you are interested it supports these
two algorithms in from map and each
between us and there are other
algorithms like this level propagation
world sub-communities thing like really
depending on what you are doing you
might be interested on using one or
another so here a little bit of code
this is the like the function we used to
call these these methods for our graph
so we need just to give us input the
graph socket with our structure and
directly these community methods are
methods of of this graph objects most of
them just need the way to the parameter
but some of them can be more fine-tuned
with with the other parameter and there
are three of them actually that do not
return directly the castling but
returned rather a dendogram
so you can decide as we should because
they are the approaches here article and
you can decide which level you want to
take so so this is the case for fast VDV
wall trap the h between us so again
depending on on your approach you might
need one of the other
and the kind of things that we want that
community clustering that with our with
our structure is and the things we want
to bring forth when we do the community
classic Network we define the grass is
first of all that the better stance are
enforced to be in the same loop because
it is like what nature does with them so
that they form interaction between them
and they they usually don't move a lot
they move more related to the other
element then because of the same reason
we don't what the a single beta strand
is in a in a group because that doesn't
make sense and we want things that are
more or less compact in a space and that
could match things that will move in
reality so we have applied a different
approaches depending on the type of
structure that we were working with so
for the case of structures that are all
alpha helical we have used this fast
greedy algorithm which was the first one
I showed and and this is the kind of
bookends we've been getting with much
what we what it makes sense for for for
refinement and one of the things that we
do is refinement like iteratively we do
it a couple of times and at the moment
what we do after different grouping is
let each of the Alice's to refine
individually but we think it will be
better to get to uses dendogram I I say
this method returns and then putting in
a different level so that we get for
example another level of the of groups
that is not so so big I mean the
indicator but here I leave each of the
elf's perforated it's a lot of groups so
maybe computational is not the best idea
and we are exploring that and in the
case of alpha-beta structures we make a
mixture of the different algorithm and
we we do some some combination so what
we do is first we use the infamous using
a a version of our graph that has been
figured and that only contains the
Petersons and that uses a distance all
of what we know
which more or less sensible for better
Sun then we use the facility on the
feedback graph all UDL sciences and then
we merge the resource we have an obvious
consequence that is that the youth will
not have those voice alpha sine beta
strands much but depending on your fault
this could be what you want so for
example in this first case and the
second one which are this kind of thing
which is what you have the beta strand
in the middle analysis on the sides here
you also have like to let us hear this
make sense and in this case we have like
more like a site like repeats of aliases
and betas lamb and I'm here as I said
maybe we could put another level in
which we join Alice's and data sense but
still this has to be quite good results
at the moment and this is the code for
these two states classroom it was just
to show you again the the options that
you have in Python a graph to to select
by by some of the properties of the of
the vertices like in this case whether
they are a better stance or a Silas's
and and yeah well as I said what we do
is just filter use the first algorithm
filtered use the second one and then
merge the wrestle Cena in a dictionary
but I guess the point is well what is
useful circuit is this approach has been
helping us solve new structures well the
answer is yes so this program I
mentioned our Kimball the shredder is
using these groups that we get from the
community clustering and it's using them
to improve both at the rotation step and
at the translation step model and with
this help with this refinement of
rigidbody group we've been able to to
solve a set of not only based structures
but also on knowledge structures and
here a brilliant example of how this
input output of the refinement looks
like so these were modeled from myosin
which is one of the floating that
carries things in your muscles and it's
an a life cycle
but this is one of the model so the
certain model was in is in blue
and the model that has been subject to
this refinement has changed and has
become 0.47 and so closer to the final
solution of attractor species a lot in
terms of facing a lot of facing a
structure if you were starting at one
point to and you went down to 0.7
probably mean that you will say if your
structure so it's quite good in terms of
of the result but other groups they do
correspond I can show you because it's
actually this kind of fun - yeah because
I look for would be probably and this is
only a part of probably will be two rows
in there yeah so well in completion what
we are doing is using community classes
as a way to automatically determine
which are these best rigidbody groups in
order to help us determining structures
of unknown protein and while we have
some promising results already with this
naive description that we have at the
moment but we could include more things
more things rather than just distances
away and or different super steps for
deciding the group's further assignments
and we need to try it on more structure
and actually it will be may be useful
using this powerful tool that is
describing the the protein as a graph to
use when we have more than one like say
bad model model that won't distant the
model model try to extract information
of a few of them and try to determine
which are the best part of the structure
that we can use for example or how to
merge them into a single model or make
analogies model so this could be useful
with this class description and well
last but not least I would like to to
our knowledge well as my group the
reaction volatile especially my
supervisor is a venison and my colleague
Massimo samito because thanks to to him
I have learned hello
I also our collaborators in in chemists
in the group of rondalee Dominguez even
in general a group of Jewish Alex then
to the institutions and especially the
tax payer society
officials that has to border my work and
I also want to to mention because this
is a Python conference and I'm really
glad and I'm really thankful to the
Python committee which I know I knew
offline for a free online for a lot of
time but now knowing them and now face
to face is really great and I'm learning
a lot with this conference and well I
want also to thank you for your
attention if you have any questions now
about the work piece if it was them but
also if you want to to contact me later
on and so I would be really happy to
transfer your question questions okay I
would like to add about the first
gradual or if I mean how it were sir
which is the advantages of other other
if I don't know
with I can see we have following like an
empirical approach here so we have tried
all eight of them and the one that were
dress it is it is the one what using but
you can read a little bit about the
literature of each of them and it's the
ones that do like more like in the case
of a 3d ideological approach and stuff
like by making groups and merging them
are working quite working our case some
of the other ones if you don't feel the
if you don't put as much money
information if you just with the
distance they are not working so good
but really really depends on on the case
actually one of the things I show that
this in the combined use of for the
structures with alpha and beta in
principle info map should be really
useful and powerful when you have
directed graphs and that's our case but
in Enda structures we have test was
working well with our undirected graph
on producing the risotto
okay so I got lost in one part so I
understand that in the in the experiment
to measure the structure of the proteins
so you got the amplitude you didn't get
the phases and you needed the phases so
what I got lost is how come you actually
have a database of other proteins with
their amplitude and their faces is it
because you measure them with better
with better stuff or because you
calculate them in I didn't get Wow
okay let me go back to this well in the
database what we have is the coordinates
we have the Mobile's of the proteins but
let me just go back to the yes right the
thing is that once once you know already
that the coordinates of the structure
let me go yes you can compute what will
be the analysis is that representation
at a simplified representation of this
model but how come you you do have the
amplitudes and phases for some proteins
and for others don't but yeah how come
how do you measure because we solve them
at first but like mother like a
mathematical way of no no no very
mentally okay okay
agent with molecular replacement or we
tell FME with the magnetic resonance or
with now with dielectric microscopy and
also in crystallography that if their
molecular equation is not the only way
to get these faces in x-ray diffraction
experiments there are some experimental
method like you can put atoms that the
diffraction of heavy atoms and measure
them for there are other and those
methodologies are much more they're much
harder to get or they're very mentally
yeah for example this experimental
facing mixed ray diffraction means that
you need to the rivet eyes your protein
and add something there that's really
this way is much faster and nice but so
it improves the performance and you
exploited information that is already
there you have
so remember when I show you the Nobel
Prize Max Perutz
for the movie that was because in that
period actually it was so difficult to
solve a structure that if you solve a
structure you got the Nobel Prize now
you answer that now you now there are
Nobel Prize for for for fracture because
but it is for much more bigger
structures or enzymes things that are
being no sorry things they did it in the
widdy's techniques or Megan Barroso did
it actually through through experimental
phase II in crystallography but in words
are because you don't know at the time
you don't know anything now we have a
database of all the structure you can
use this technique and you can say okay
my structure is similar so I can use the
phases from that but I debated at the
time you didn't have anything but the
thing is that even if you have some time
structures are similar if they are not
very similar then it doesn't work and
allow their release application allows
you to extend the to extent there you
know the probability to solve even in
some cases when when it's not so easy so
the issue is that I know that visually
all of these looks really similar but in
order for the molecular displacement to
succeed it must be really really
equivalent so even even these kind of
deviations we make it fail there's one
part that I missed you in a single piece
that you cut off at some point later
can you still deform that just slightly
or does it remain rigid body no no yes
maybe you say that yeah I mean it's
clear in this one so I used the full
thing like the whole model to do the
community lesson and get the groups but
then once I've got these models they
each of these different color thing will
be the financer different groups so I
will perform like in this case like
three molecular replacement with three
different models all of them annotated
in order to do this rigid body
refinement but in each group it's a
rigid body the atoms do not move with
respect to the other atoms in the same
group
service table yeah and I never have
single atoms in any group I mean always
they are one second instruction element
at least
hello can you go back to the previous
slide I think because we're the
resolution of the method is is displayed
we have like angstroms underneath there
are like four types of groupings and
you're comparing how much accurate you
get with the answers it is a technical
question because I finish this one yet
if I am correct in the resolution of
x-ray crystallography
it's around 1 & 2 angstroms writing if
you're lucky and more like Aaron - quite
good sorry
so how is meaningful that we get to
under 1 ounce terms of gross mess maybe
they are because actually you don't get
anywhere experimentally right well yeah
but we yeah I understand but what you
care is in order to get faces that are
good good another person isn't to solve
your structure and the the molecular
replacement really sensitive to to do
that this is really very close but that
model you are using for my girl
placement was obtained with that
resolution of 1 angstroms
Oh more or less so I don't know even the
mother yes problem maybe not the best so
yeah
exciting yes well I don't get how you
can benefit from having less than one
national solution if the experimental
information doesn't get anywhere else at
that yeah maybe it will because it
should be good enough with one Anson
which is the best available and
experimental but that yeah I will start
this collaborative oh yeah well yes but
at the end I mean the independently of
which experimental resolution you had at
the end you have a mobile with
coordinates in 3d space and you assign
there are some kind of puzzles in which
we put these errors for example to be
factors in the case of PDV structures
and and but you are being have an
average console at the end I don't know
how to maybe when we're gonna discuss it
every because this is not Python that
sorry sir
sorry about that question no no hello
and just a small technical question how
did you how did you define the grabs
from the protein did so I guess that
every note is it's a residue or or an
atom maybe even maybe I missed that I I
won't tell you this quickly because the
previous talk about Maxima was
explaining these but in my in this case
they were representing vectors in my
case each of the vectors are
representing one single secondary
structural element so one better term or
one alpha helix or each of these
elements here okay and then the the
edges have the business when
proportional to the listen yeah
hi so I'd like you to comment a little
bit what your experience with biopython
dot DB has been because I'm doing like
system like I've been doing large-scale
structural analysis and I've trying to
use these two two parts pretty much
spent 5 DB and I've run into some
trouble because out of the numbering in
diversity in the structure is messed up
and this kind of thing so what's your
experience with that I think that
doesn't depend on the tool that you use
to pass it because it is a problem of
the actual format and a ton of the
scientists using the format and not
respecting the standard and these
independently of whether you develop
your own part of a piece of CD or you
use bi or Python or you use another one
you will find these things and they have
different options for handling with
problems and some of them may be more
robust or less oh I don't know because I
don't know so much large Canaanites and
massimo has been using biopython for
reading all the PDB and and it's been
yeah the MMC but but but I have still to
see the time if he's moving to MMC fact
is not giving problems and also because
all the well you know if you've been
doing a structure ice but there are so
many other tools related also with the
bessel visualization of the structure or
with doing some things with different
tools that we need to adapt to this new
format and it will be I think step by
step yes yes
yeah actually this this API I think it
depends on what you want to get but for
many of the things that otherwise you
will have to do like briefs and text
mining of the of the header of the PDB
file you can really use a deity from the
PDB in Europe which is really really
useful okay that was great a potential
users well thanks and now I would just
want to mention that we have the coffee
break and afterwards we will do a group
photo on the stage so please be
[Applause]